President Trump wants Hillary to run
again me too and speaking of hashtag me
too we'll discuss the me to meme and
have saccharine slacktivism hurts real
victims then we'll be joined by possibly
the first Democrat ever to grace the
michael knowles show couch to run down
the latest list of left wing talking
points
finally Ariel Davidson and His Eminence
Paul Bois joined the panel of deplorable
z' to talk America's quiet victory over
Isis John McCain's spurious spurious
nationalism and California's official
third gender that's what I am I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
we have got so much to talk about today
obviously we have our first Democrat in
studio
I guess there's Dave Rubin but I read
somewhere that Dave is a Nazi all right
er so I'm just gonna take that at face
value certainly the the first elected
Democrat that we have in studio we'll
get to him and ask him which a chapter
of my book was his favorite but let's
start with I think the second most cough
F a press conference in history the
first of course was when President
Reagan fired all of the air-traffic
controllers this one was very close
president Trump yesterday Hillary please
run again look when they take a knee
there's plenty of time to do knees and
there's plenty of time to do lots of
other things but when you take a knee
sheet well that's why she lost the
election I mean honestly it's that
thinking that is the reason she lost the
election when you go down and take a
knee or any other way you're sitting
essentially for our great national
anthem you're disrespecting our flag and
you're disrespecting our country and the
NFL should have suspended some of these
players for one game not fire him
suspended him for one game and then if
they did it again it could have been two
games in three games and then for the
season you wouldn't have people
disrespecting our country right now and
if Hillary Clinton actually made the
statement that in a forum sitting down
during the playing of our great national
anthem is not disrespectful
then I fully understand why she didn't
win I know I I mean I mean look there
are a lot of reasons he didn't win
including the fact that she was not good
at what you did but I will tell you that
is something that I had just heard about
and I think that I think that her
statement in itself is very
disrespectful to our country I love him
so much I can't get over it he this is
why we elected this guy I sometimes
worry that people who aren't from New
York don't even appreciate this stuff as
much as I do he he actually set this up
by the way he tweeted out he said some
people want Hillary to run again please
Hillary run again so he sets it up at
this press conference they asked the
question and he knocks it out of the
park please Hillary run again and he
brushes her off says well this is why
there are times to kneel there are times
not to kneel and and I know it seems
like a throwaway statement what he's
saying is I'm not an ideologue I am NOT
a rationalist I'm not an ideologue I
simply have a view of respecting the
country I have a traditional view
traditionalist view in some ways of
America and you got to respect the
country I don't you don't need to be
fired maybe you get suspended for one
game maybe two games I don't know and
then to say I see why Hillary lost well
there are a lot of reasons why Hillary
lost but that's one of them it's just
he's unrelenting he never stops I mean
this is this is what we elected this is
what we've been waiting for on the
Republican side for a long time is a guy
who will make it will just stand firm
against this cultural onslaught from the
mainstream media and from the
entertainment complex he'll just stand
firm and say no no I'm pretty sure
that's why Hillary lost now I think I'm
gonna respect the flag great stuff
excellent press conference very very
cafe I agree with him of course he wants
Hillary won me too speaking of me too
we talked about this a little yesterday
Alyssa Milano sent out a tweet which
launched this huge social media campaign
it's all over Facebook and Twitter she
said and this is in response to the
Harvey Weinstein scandal it turns out he
raped like every aspiring actress in all
of Hollywood and this is a widespread
problem in Hollywood for a very long
time now it's all coming to light people
are talking about the horrific incidents
that have happened to them and she
tweeted out and said if you've been
sexually harassed or assaulted write me
too as a reply to this tweet there's the
problem this there are a few problems
with the slacktivism with this hashtag
activism but the first is in her
launching it she says if you've been
sexually assaulted or harassed those are
categorically different things those are
categorically different they're both bad
we should stop both I suppose one is a
is a heinous crime one is a
assaulting somebody's sold as well as
their body violating their liberty and
the other is being rude and untoward and
you know maybe the guy at the office
winks at his secretary
that's all terrible too quite different
than rape and to conflate those two is
offensive and disrespectful toward the
victims of actual rape now a men are
virtue signaling back because that's how
the internet works with the hashtags
hashtag I will and hashtag how I will
change so here are just a few of them
hashtag I will promote women's voices
believe survivors and work to end rape
culture and purity culture two sides of
the same patriarchal coin how I will
change I will listen to women more
closely seeking to understand before
seeking to be understood then if it
helps I will act I will listen more
learn more acknowledge more in support
more I'm willing to have more courageous
conversations or use those courageous
words how courageous how I will change
means acknowledging my own capacity for
harmful behavior and taking
responsibility for unlearning that
toxicity I don't really take issue with
the premise here that men can be dogs
and they should behave themselves I take
issue with the supposed surprise the
shock the earnestness of the tweeters I
think it's mostly feigned I think it's
fake but some might be real because
these people are utopians and they think
that mankind can be perfected with just
a few more regulations a little less
freedom a little more effort that isn't
going to happen and living in delusion
will help nobody
so let's dispel some of the delusion
around this we begin with the courageous
conversations what is courageous about
echoing the dominant cultural meme what
is courageous about saying you're always
right I'm always wrong whatever the left
tells us is true even if the statistics
are spurious that's true I'll believe
anything
there isn't a rape culture in the United
States that was one of the allegations
there was a rape culture there was no
rape culture in the United States rape
happens this is because we're fallen
people and crime happens and murder
happens and awful things happen and will
always happen because we're not going
back to the Garden of Eden
this is
an earthly paradise and human nature
isn't perfectible that's going to happen
but you know the rape culture is this
Pakistan
that's a rape a culture that
institutionalizes and through its own
cultural mores creates venues in which
rape is approved of that is a rape
culture there is no approval of rape in
the United States the to tweet a
trending hashtag alleging rape culture
undermines the rape culture right it
undermines your own claim it's a
defeater for your ridiculous argument
the the hashtags too are empty virtue
signaling it is saccharine it is it is
it's slacktivism that accomplishes
nothing it reminds me of I don't know if
people remember this Kony 2012 did you
remember in in 2011 or 2012 there is
this I remember Michael do you remember
this it was everywhere
Kony 2012 he was some warlord in Uganda
and some filmmaker said we're gonna stop
Kony this year and then every little
dummy on Twitter and Facebook posted
about it and they felt they were doing
something they felt they were
accomplishing something they
accomplished nothing he's still at large
it's it is a useless it is to make
yourself feel good to give the
impression of doing something it I've
heard this described about smoking
cigars and I will acknowledge it the
nice thing about smoking is you feel
like you're doing something but you're
really just sitting down and not doing
anything that's slacktivism Michelle
Obama did that she held up a sign when
those girls were kidnapped by Boko Haram
in Nigeria the sign said no joke hashtag
bringbackourgirls
that's the Sun this is the courageous
piece of paper or hashtag your husband
is the president of United States if you
want to bring back the girls you can
bring back the girls now perhaps the
issue isn't as calm as simple as all of
that perhaps there are geopolitics at
play that complicate things don't
pretend that your hashtag is doing
anything it's accomplishing absolutely
nothing
also don't tweet about it if you're a
guy don't tweet I will I'm with you I
these guys these like fake feminists
sensitive earnest nice guys they're like
the creepiest guys around do not but
they are creeps I would not let my
fiance near any of them they are get
women do not believe them
the feminist men protest too much
methinks
next if you've been raped go to the
police go to the police do not go to
your professor do not go to your
administrator on campus do not pass go
do not collect $200 it is a serious
crime it is possibly the most serious
crime if it has happened make sure that
it is prosecuted to the full extent of
the law we have a system for prosecuting
crimes it's called the criminal justice
system it's not the sort of crime to be
dealt with by campus tribunals this
leads into another aspect though we have
a criminal justice system to protect the
rights of the accusers but also to
protect the rights of the accused so the
people who have had a crime committed
against them and also those of a accuse
of doing it these campus tribunals have
been absolutely demolishing the due
process rights of the accused in in
countless cases but a lot of the tweets
that have been coming with I will or I
you know this is what I will do they say
that will always believe of people who
allege that they have been raped Hillary
Clinton said this during the campaign
which is quite ironic because she
smeared the people who alleged rape
against her own husband someone might
ask why would anyone make up a rape why
would anyone allege that they've been
raped if they haven't I don't know it's
pretty weird man but it does happen in
just the last eight years there have
been five instances five major instances
of this presumably many others there was
obviously the Rolling Stone UVA rape
hoax this was a major story in Rolling
Stone a girl alleged she had been
gang-raped at a fraternity it didn't
happen the story absolutely fell apart
they had to retract the whole thing at
UC Santa Cruz a few years ago a girl
paid someone on Craigslist to beat her
up and then she alleged that she had
been raped that also fell apart in 2013
a University of Wyoming student posted a
rape threat against herself in a campus
Facebook group that also was uncovered
but not before it caused a lot of
anxiety to the campus community a lot of
other people 2009 a hospice Hofstra
student had consensual sex with five
guys at once her boyfriend found out
and said you look like you've just had
sex with a lot of guys and she said I've
been raped he said go to the police she
said no that I don't need to and then
they went to the police anyway they
arrested these guys they threw them in
jail only because there happened to be a
video of this event why don't want to
know what were these guys let off the
hook for it because it the video showed
that it was consensual but nevertheless
the allegation was made it could have
ruined these guys lives in 2013 a
University of Florida student falsely
claims she was raped in a parking lot
then she said it was false but intended
to show a greater truth so she it was a
complete lie but then it was the lie was
meant to serve the greater truth and
then later she admitted it's because her
parents were pressuring her to graduate
from college and she probably wasn't
going to do that conservative columnist
George Will was accused of not taking
rape seriously in a letter by four
Democratic senators because he made
these exact same points and he responded
in exactly the right way
he said he said he takes a sexual
assault and rape much more seriously
than they do you know some would prefer
it if professors and campus tribunals
dealt with this crime some would prefer
it if judges juries and executioner's
dealt with it the the we in the latter
category are taking this issue much more
seriously and the people who are
engaging in frivolous slacktivism are
doing nothing but hurting a very serious
issue all right on that note now that
we've covered the gamut from silly Trump
conferences to rape let's bring on our
guest today we have four term California
Assemblyman Mike Gatto Mike thank you
for being here it's great to be here now
you have the distinct privilege
maybe the distinct terror and
disadvantage of being the first Democrat
politician to ever come on our show so
thank you for making me either either
very brave or very stupid that's right
well that'll be left for the audience to
judge I guess I have a hunch of which
one it is my first question for you
obviously you and I have a lot in common
you're a Democrat politician I am the
best-selling author of reasons to vote
for Democrats a comprehensive guide
which which was the most compelling
chapter in my book did you think well so
I have to ask you has anyone ever gotten
a copy of your book and
oh my gosh is blank this there there
have been a few people who were nice
once my I wanted to sort of ad-lib that
I wanted you to give me a comment is oh
my gosh oh my god well I did this copy
using you you can put it in you put it
in your office you know right next to
all of the great political philosophers
there is a professor I know who at the
end of every semester he asks his
students about reading that he assigned
that he never assigned and sees who is
the greatest bs artist so I was gonna
say then I guess page 117 is the reason
why I'm well I'm really thank you so
much it's I appreciate your reading it
even just right now because I do
appreciate that you're willing to come
on and talk to Republicans right now the
parties are so completely polarized that
people aren't willing to do that you're
one of the few I don't want to say
you're reasonable I think that would be
going way too far and maybe I'll call
you semi-reasonable so we probably agree
on a great many things I want to ignore
those completely and only talk about
what we disagree on sure there are a lot
of Democratic talking points that are
going around now that I think are bunk I
think there's a lot of Democratic
politicians think they're bunk - can we
go through a few of these and maybe
happier this all right by the way the
dialogue reason is the whole reason I'm
here I think it's so important right now
that you know I mean everybody knows how
polarize this country is but I think
it's more important than ever that we
talk that the two sides talk it is it is
impressive that you're you're doing that
because I talk about this sometimes on
the show I think there were two kinds of
debate their debates were you score
points and you just yeah I got my point
and haha I've smacked you down and then
there but I don't get anything out of
that I don't in any way benefit from
that but there are debates where even
rarely I'll change my mind you know I
was pro-abortion I was pro-choice I had
lunch with a bioethicists a mana show up
by the end and a lunch of his pro-life a
rare occasion but people can change
their minds with discuss things first
question first talking point did el
Presidente the Donald himself did
President Trump sheet Hillary Clinton
out of the presidency so I think if you
read the
the more sensible articles on this you
will find out that President Putin wants
the American public to believe that this
happened he wants the American public to
lose faith in our elections he wants the
American public to to think that he is
that powerful and more importantly he
wants Russians to believe that he is so
powerful that he's pulling the strings
in the biggest superpower on earth I
think there's a real danger with that
narrative because our elections at risk
yeah I've been a i've been somebody
who's raised this issue that we have to
be careful about voting machines we have
to be careful about vote-by-mail ballots
people can take them and happens all the
time
happen in Hollywood in a very very
recent election but this idea that our
entire democracy has our entire
Republican form of government has been
hacked or or stolen by the Russians is
so detrimental to people having faith in
the system that's that is such a mature
analysis of it because I think I even
know Democrats on the grassroots level
and members of my family friends of mine
who say it Putin is controlling the
government and Donald Trump is a
Manchurian Kami ridiculous things right
Donald Trump the guy we've known for 40
years is really a secret plant of KGB
operative Vladimir Putin yeah he's got a
hard time controlling his own country I
mean I you know when these rumors
started going out there I mean he was
sort of that danger of there being
another type of orange revolution or
people you know a real strong
alternative coming forth and so you know
I mean he spread these I think he's been
active in spreading these rumors of
course and that that there I think is
the fake news right people allege the
fake news I pride myself on being a
strictly fake news program but that
there is the fake news right now I don't
think anyone is under the misconception
that Vladimir Putin is a benevolent
forest he loves the United States he
wants to do as well but clearly he's
caused some chaos even by crafting the
narrative that he's caused some chaos
and probably right
the New York Times suggested that Donald
Trump did not pay income taxes for two
decades this was blown up by my twin
sister Rachel Maddow we have evidence
that he did pay they tried this on Mitt
Romney
said that Mitt Romney didn't pay his
income taxes I promise you they'll try
it on the next Republican nominee does
an attack like that does it work does it
hold any water does it work in the other
direction probably not Republicans are
the greedy awful capitalists why does
that attack why does that stick around
well I think that first of all people
are justifiably upset because there's a
huge gap between the rich and the poor
in this country right now and I think we
really run the risk of being sort of the
opposite of what the founding fathers
wanted which was a country of Galit
arianism where everybody is more or less
equal and has a not equal opportunity
that being said people probably don't
understand the the arcane tax code I
don't understand our arcane tax code my
taxes in a decade well I certainly don't
do although I hope you pay taxes on that
mic is pointing out my lovely $400 check
from mr. ben shapiro i confirm he did
not pay taxes on the people the
california government
I promise you they don't watch my show
and I Ben did ask because this is the
original check he said oh great you
didn't catch the check and I said no no
there's this wonderful thing called
mobile deposit so I get to cash a check
and I get to frame and get it on my show
but but what happened I mean obviously
on people in real estate like like our
president um you know it if you have one
year where you have one huge loss you
can carry forward that loss you're 10
years 20 years indefinitely so I'm
guessing what happened I mean he should
release his tax returns we'd probably
know but I'm guessing what happened is
he had one year where he lost a ton of
money and he's carried forward those
losses for all these years and he
probably hasn't paid much taxes because
of those losses so we know at least 10
years later we know in because that was
what my sister Rachel Maddow released he
paid 38 million dollars of taxes in ten
years so I'm sure yeah he had a 95 he
had a huge loss I assume he wrote off
those losses as well he should but he
didn't write off for 20 years at least
right you know and the question you
bring up is you know there's this big
gap between the rich and the poor the
middle class is shrunk and there's a
widening gap I'm not in the upper 1%
even with my blank book I mean I didn't
five percent but why do I care if some
guy gets really rich why do I care I
have a girl I have an unbelievable
standard of living I'm in the top
probably tenth of a percent of the world
wealth and income let me give you two
reasons why you should care so first of
all our country was founded on the idea
that there was no royalty that's
actually written in our constitution you
know no titles of royalty and when you
have a system where you know I mean
where Paris Hilton's great-grandchildren
are Kim Kardashian's great-grandchildren
will be wealthier than yours no matter
what you do no matter how many wonderful
clever books us and first you I plan on
writing a lot of blank clever bras but
but I mean we see study after study
dynastic wealth for some families it
holds true for many it disappears within
two three generations not not completely
disappears they'll maybe they'll move
from the top quintile to the second
topic win tile well let me give you a
reason even clear a reason why white
people should care if you go to the to
Blaine Osiris you know the rich go to
work in armored SUVs the pores are in
slums and they're very upset do we want
to live in a country like that we don't
the last time the gap between rich and
poor was so significant was 1929 how'd
that turn out I mean I think that we're
at a real danger unless we have a
thriving middle class and that's why
everybody should care about this I'm not
saying confiscate wealth I'm not saying
but I think we do need to level the
playing field well I will grant you and
I I will also point out that at the time
of the founding of the country there
were a handful of extraordinarily
wealthy people and a bunch of not
wealthy people and yeah wasn't no income
well sure there was them but also the
framers however you make a very good
point how did it turn out in 1929
we got Democrats elected for four terms
five terms so I agree it's something to
worry about if if I have to worry about
another Franklin Roosevelt tax me more
that's fine by me
speaking of the slums speaking of all of
this these housing difficulties you were
at a very good piece in the LA Times
about affordable housing in Los Angeles
now I just to fill people in I don't
know if it
people follow this more local story
housing in LA is awful and the
homelessness problem is unbelievable so
friends of mine live in a very nice
building it's a luxury building a fifth
of that has to go to low income so
you've got drug dealers crazy people
living in this or the developers nieces
and nephews or the developers nieces and
there's a lot of corruption in this town
in with but you you're in this luxury
building and then around the corner
three blocks away is Skid Row is Skid
Row which I don't see anything
compassionate about letting drug dealers
and crazy people live on the streets to
destroy a neighborhood and kill each
other why is LA
why has this government failed so much
to address the problems of housing and
homelessness well I think there's been a
fundamental lack of honesty you know we
just talked about the gap between the
rich and the poor nobody wants to
address the big problems nobody wants to
address things like the Federal Reserve
printing money which is driven the cost
of a loan down has driven property
values up so that they're so crazy that
now you've got people who are so
frustrated with their inability to buy a
house that they're saying okay the
government should subsidize me buying a
house and that gets to be a little bit
odd and you have these weird situation
where we have more subsidies more
socialistic policies going into place
and then I also think nobody wants to
address the root cause of homelessness
or the various root causes of
homelessness I mean California just a
few years ago put in place this ballot
initiative where we released on the
streets a lot of people for for a lot of
crimes were otherwise they would have
been getting the the the attention they
deserve getting the the drug rehab that
they deserve when they're incarcerated
and yet those people are now just on the
streets and people think that
homelessness is only caused by the high
price of houses that's not correct it's
caused by mental illness a lot of
various things a drug use a lot of
things that we have to address all of
them if we're gonna be honest about it
and and I love that point especially in
the mental illness because when we
develop these psychotropic drugs in the
1980s we emptied out the insane asylums
because they people were fine trouble is
once you feel fine you stop taking your
psychotropic drugs that's right and you
know when someone suggests that maybe we
ought to put criminals in prison or that
we ought to put crazy people into
facilities where they can take
medication and see the world more
clearly
they say that's not compassionate that's
bits depriving them of some freedom is
there really any Liberty or any
compassion in letting these people that
live in squalor on the street well
that's that's that's the law of
unintended consequences right I mean
proposition 47 passed by all the voters
in the state of California where the
majority of voters in the state of
California reduced all of these drug
crimes from from a felony to a
misdemeanor the difference between a
felony misdemeanor of course is the
judge could look that person in the eye
and say unless you go to rehab unless
you get help for this drug addiction
that you've got you're gonna go to jail
for a long time and this scared a lot of
people straight and because now this is
a mandatory misdemeanor which means in
Los Angeles County you'll spend about 12
hours in jail you've got a lot of people
not even addressing their addiction and
that's a real problem and it's
counterintuitive because a lot of my
progressive friends say oh let these
people yeah okay yeah our society is too
hard on drug offenders i stipulate that
but we've got to somehow give the tools
to judges and juries so that people can
find the rehab that they need so that
they're not using drugs and stealing and
screwing up all of our neighborhoods
all right last Democrat talking point is
we have so much news to get to obviously
the Las Vegas shooting largest mass
shooting in American history the gun
debate is always back front and center
[Music]
there have been some proposals on how to
curb this problem because they say maybe
we'll get rid of bump stocks but you can
bump fire from regular ar-15 it's a
little more difficult also with any bump
fire it's been very difficult to aim so
it only really works if you're shooting
at a gigantic crowd of people is the
only answer here to repeal the Second
Amendment you have a lot of people on
the Left proposing this is that the
point where we are right now in in
American society we want to give up our
right to keep and bear arms well so I'll
make three points on this the first one
is I got a text from a very successful
TV journalist who's a reporter for a
major Network major figure source one
soon right right after this this right
after this incident and she's texted me
and said oh my god why don't people
realize that the Second Amendment only
applied to muskets and below button went
on this horrible ramp and and I wrote
her back and I said yeah and I don't
think I I guess that you should agree
that the First Amendment isn't applied
to this conversation on our iPhone and
it was like I mean excellent
excellent analogy I mean people's ideas
of rights being transitory even frozen
in time it's it you throw out the whole
Constitution with that of course but the
second thing is and again I see a total
lack of honesty I mean most of the most
horrific crimes I mean you probably know
my father was murdered by someone with a
handgun I mean most of the most horrific
crimes are committed in our cities with
handguns and there is no honesty in the
debate people do not want to address
this a mass shooting gets our attention
I realize that but you know and and what
those people suffered through is
horrible and nobody should have to
suffer through that but I'd like to see
people talk more about the root causes
of gun violence which is more that more
often than not caused by handgun the
third thing is if Democratic politicians
want to repeal the second member if any
politician wants to repeal the second
meant they should be honest about it
they should say the Constitution against
us people it's ours to amend Thomas
Jefferson said famously every 25 years
or so we should amend the Constitution
it's used bloodier language but but if
people want to do that the people that
people own the Constitution it belongs
to all of us and if they want to repeal
the Second Amendment and it's a movement
that that people should be honest but we
shouldn't dance around the issue I've
got to help people feel now I for one do
not believe in that but but I you know
politicians who do should come out and
say they should be honest uh you're
you're channeling this should scare you
by the way you're channeling my feelings
at least on the honesty point of this
because I think all the time when they
bring up assault rifles which have been
a legal for 80 years and then they say
assault weapons which is a term that was
made up in the mid 90s to conflate
regular rifles with assault rifles they
look scary they're they're big and scary
they look like machine guns and so we
say okay we got to get rid of those if
we get rid of those we'll be fine but as
you point out what the awful murder of
your father handguns are are the the
real problem in gun crime two-thirds of
so-called gun violence is middle-aged
guys killing themselves and more people
are killed by hands and feet every year
then are killed by any sort of rifle
including assault rifles or shotguns
assault weapons quote-unquote or
shotguns the honesty in this debate I I
really only see honesty on the right
among a handful of Democrats who
willing to have the courage to go out
there like you Joe Manchin other
Democrats who are willing to face the
issue seriously and but a total of
dishonesty permeating the rest of the
debate is there any way to fix that I
don't know you know as long as both
parties are raising money off of these
tragedies then I think we're gonna
continue to have this lack of meaningful
debate I've never been so depressed with
with politics in America than I was
after this Las Vegas shooting I mean
literally a guy like me who's been in
politics for a long time in and out of
politics I'm cynical and jaded as the
rest of them I was so depressive getting
a fundraising email from Democratic
candidates dancing around the Second
Amendment issue getting getting
fundraising I mean they also the
Republican Congress congressional
candidate who's given away bump stocks I
mean come on I mean just give me a break
people can we can get some honesty I
mean the guy who the LAPD has a profile
the guy who killed my father
they think he was a petty drug user
someone who's high out of his mind yeah
I would much rather see our society
address the drug problem much rather see
us address mental illness and things
like that I think we can get a lot of
headway and I also I'm not as glamorous
to address the preponderance of crimes
that affect people that affect the rest
of their lives
then these one-off spectacularly awful
crimes that are spectacular for a reason
right because they're not the common
crime that happens correct absolutely
right well all right that's fine I like
I really enjoy going through the the
talking points with you give me time to
all to support you at some well I'm sure
you're disappointed when we talk about
all of this news that we've had to get
to but but it is great because I bet you
that if we were on like a cable news
show or something and it just had to be
what do you think about Trump yes or no
what do you think about this talking
about yes or no you you just have to you
have to stick to the talking points
maybe you wouldn't maybe you'd have the
courage of your convictions I think most
people would do that excellent we have
to get to the news we have so much news
to talk about we need Mike to just say
the craziest most wild and absurd
left-wing things you've ever heard but
you can't see that unless you go to
daily wire calm right now we want to
thank all of our current subscribers
it's just $10 a month or $100 for an
annual membership you'll get me you'll
get the Andrew Clavin show you'll get
the mention Bureau show
I know odd droning on who cares who
cares her but wait you get the leftist
tears tumblr look at this meat is so
delicious I was hoping I know I was
really hoping I could fill it up on this
fountain of Mike got our today but
unfortunately I haven't been able to yet
maybe a little later on
I'll just keep playing Trump clips you
can have yours it is the finest vessel
for leftist tears in the entire country
perhaps in the entire universe they
observed recently scientists observed
gravitational waves coming out of two
stars colliding and creating the
molecules that have forged the leftist
tears tumbler Cup it is indestructible
go to daily wire calm right now we'll be
right back
we have so much news here us-backed
forces have captured Raqqa the
self-described capital of Isis this is
so much winning Ariel
does this mean that we have officially
defeated Isis uh yes and no in some ways
so the best way to is to say to
ourselves we've taken the self
designated caliphate so we've definitely
yield a blow to the collective ego of
Isis and you know this is a top selling
point for them to attract militants from
all over the Middle East and the world
so as we look at it from a perspective
yes it's been a collective blow to their
ego now begins the actual workers
rebuilding Raqqa which I think will
present lots of challenges in the future
I also want to give a shout out to the
Kurds because the Kurds were a huge part
of this victory um it was Kurdish back
to militia as well as some Arab factions
and you know the fact that he abandoned
aim for those in Kurdistan I think it
looks really poorly given especially
given this recent victory um so you know
I guess to get to your question in terms
of the ideological defeat of Isis yes
but they're still going to be able to
communicate with one another on their
chat rooms online and and so you know
amazingly taking their physical location
but in terms of their ability which you
know is how they recruit members but in
terms of their ability to attract
followers that's still very much alive
and well so you know we've cut the blood
flow in some ways but it's still living
and existing so it's gonna we're gonna
have to address it as a local
organization you've always got to be
glass half-empty Ariel come on already
gave a shout out to the Kurds very
procures yeah you're right to
acknowledge that we have a massive
Kurdish audience we want to thank all
the thick that Kurds who are watching
the show right now I know they're great
they always team up with us when we're
fighting the bad guys and stuff your
eminence how much credit can we give
Trump here as Ariel said there's still
the Isis ideology there's still people
who
our Islamic extremists who will talk to
each other and try to organize but we
blown them all up we blew up their whole
city Barack Obama saw Isis form under
his watch he couldn't take out the city
or he didn't want to he didn't want to
take out the organization perhaps or he
didn't prioritize it how much credit can
we give dear leader well I certainly
think most of the credit belongs to the
forces on the ground who have been
fighting bravely throughout all this
these past several months their cities
are an absolute ruin
they've just been going through hell so
I definitely think we should keep them
in our thoughts and prayers right now as
they clean up the mess that Isis has
made but in terms of what Trump has done
in order to create this outcome
certainly he delegated decisions down to
the forces and the military personnel on
the ground to go ahead and take action
without getting prior approval from
Washington DC that was something that
happened in May when general mattis
announced the annihilates Isis
anihilation strategy and that has been
very very effective thus far I mean
we're just six months away and we've
already taken Raqqa so yes I do
certainly think that Trump Trump's
decision-making there certainly should
be credited with this victory I'll just
correct you on you said general mattis
and just for our bloodthirsty listeners
who love internet that would be Mad Dog
Madison yes Janice tur Mad Dog Mike the
to Obama era foreign policy doctrines
seem to have been leading from behind
and strategic patience this is quite a
change
president Trump campaigned on defeating
Isis prioritizing defeating Isis now it
looks like they are defeating Isis how
much I'm not asking how much we can give
credit to el Donald here but how much
can I blame Barack Obama one of my
favorite hobbies well the answer is you
can't blame Barack Obama at all and and
and you I mean you know Donald Trump and
his followers have got to stop taking
credit for policies that Barack Obama
put in place where you're now seeing
play out you know today or yesterday
Donald Trump sent something we did the
Dow hit 23,000 oh my gosh great great
great the reality is the Dow has been on
a
here since about 2009 at the depths of
the of the mortgage crisis that started
under Barack Obama continued under
President Trump and the reality is is
that if you own the successes you ought
to own the failures to at some point in
the next three years the next in the
Trump presidencies I'm assuming we're
going to go into recession I'd like to
see his followers own those defeats as
well I absolutely will not thank you
very much sorry go ahead success has
many fathers but failure is an orphan
and I think a lot of these policies were
put in place a long time ago and they
were going in the right direction some
have some heaven I'll grant you the
stock market we can't the Republicans
can't take total credit for the stock
market error it has been building since
2009 this seems a little different there
does seem to have been a big shift in
military policy so I'm not sure I am
willing to give Donald Trump some credit
here but I do grant it's you know Barack
Obama campaign he said GM is alive and I
was sama bin Laden's dead but of course
the work to capture Osama bin Laden had
been building for over a decade there
were almost a decade rather so yes these
there is more complication here Bill
Clinton took a lot of credit for the
great economy in the 90s probably you
could credit Ronald Reagan and George
Bush for that but I'm only going to give
credit to the Republicans and blame the
Democrats thank you very much it's
actually honest and it is it
consistently there now this is the big
story there are three genders in
California which one are you which one
am I Democratic Governor Jerry Brown a
man you know very well Mike he's signed
to the gender recognition act Sunday
which lets residents choose non-binary
on identification documents such as
driver's licenses and birth certificates
I believe I just heard Paul dois sighing
not surprised at all Arielle you know we
just had Blair white on last week we
just had on a youtuber who is
transgender biological male identifies
as a woman
what's wrong with codifying this third
gender hmm well I think it's different
from being you know from identifying as
a man or a woman that doesn't
necessarily I don't think that poses a
problem actually and I think you touched
upon that in your last podcast I think
we're
we talk about sort of non-identifying
either I'm kind of approaching this from
the statistical chance standpoint so I
do economic research as you know and a
lot of a lot of the research whether it
be from the US Census Bureau or be from
a statistical database belong to the
state it is codified by mail email this
is how we look at economic out cuts this
is how we look at average earnings this
is how we basically addressed any
statistical analysis this through
looking at the lens of mail you know so
coming at it from sort of the
statistical perspective if enough people
decide that they identify as neither
then I think this could pose some
problems down the road I know for
instance in Oregon when they did an
unspecified gender it I think it cost
something around thirty thousand dollars
to update their dot their statistical
databases Californians about ten times
the size of Oregon's um so we could be
looking at a bill of around 1/2 million
in order to make these adjustments which
if you look at California spending is
really not that much because our state
spends the time but when you look at
sort of what challenges might come down
the road I don't think enough people are
going to identify as non-binary that's
going to be a statistical problem and
but if it does sort of become the vogue
or popular way of the resistance which
has no intersectionality and the
homeworks this rhetoric that comes with
that I have no doubt that it will you
form with resistance to Donald Trump
just wait then it could be a problem and
though I you know I really don't take a
huge issue with it right now
but I do see you know at least from a
statistical sample and measuring
outcomes it could be a problem of the
future enough people decide either that
this is their form of resistance in
which case it sort of denigrate
submission or the intention of it as a
whole which was to sort of give people
who felt like they couldn't fit neither
category you know a voice or an identity
and now I could see people using it as a
political form of resistance yes
absolutely
and that's and of course the issue is
that there isn't a third gender there is
not a third gender right there is a very
minuscule number of people who were born
intersex hermaphroditic they had both
sexual organs in some cases they have
crazy chromosomes that don't fit male or
female those are that is a vanishingly
small number of people and there are a
slightly larger number of people who are
either male or female who have a
psychological affliction that makes them
think that they are the other gender or
desperately wanting the other gender or
feel a metaphysical level that they are
the other gender Atlas and I identify as
an author I'm not an author but I
identify as one I have empathy on this
subject but Mike no one really thinks
there's a third gender is there some
good being done to society by indulging
in this delusion well let me start with
with a couple principles and the first
one hopefully means something to a lot
of your audience which is simply just
live and let live it doesn't hurt
anybody to allow people to be called a
pronoun or a gender that they want I
disagree with what Arielle said a great
amount I think that transgender people
face a lot of stigma in our society I
can't imagine anybody wanting to go
through that just as a form of political
protest against Trump I'll make the bold
prediction here in 2017 that that's not
going to happen I think you know this is
really just comes down to live and let
live why does not let people live the
way that they want to live I don't think
it hurts anybody and I think that this
thing gives a modicum of respect and
dignity to people who who want it but
does it I mean that is the question is
the road to hell paved with good
intentions because one might say well
who cares if a man pretend not only
pretends that he's a woman but pretends
that he's a mythical undefined third
gender what it doesn't really affect me
it doesn't affect my bottom line it
doesn't affect my bank account or
something but you know we're not just
material creatures we learn as Winston
Churchill said when great forces are on
the move in the world we learned that we
are spirits not animals there is an
insistence if the government is going to
say that there is a third gender then
the government is telling me you have to
view sir reality unreality as reality
with the full coercion and compulsion of
the law they're telling me that I have
to look at the world and pretend that
it's something that it isn't
your eminence Paul bois is there any
evidence here
that there are that there are bad
consequences from this that the road to
hell is paved with good intentions well
the road to hell we are on Michael Ball
blog coming live from the Vatican with
good intentions I mean yeah maybe 50
years ago this isn't even just about
making transgenders feel good about
themselves as the the bathroom debate
was about this is just this is your like
you said this is the government just
legislating complete fantasy I mean if
they want to be ideologically consistent
here why don't they just go ahead and
just say you can put whatever you want
you know say that you're a unicorn say
that you're a Raggedy Ann doll whatever
it is you want to come up with you know
the possibilities are endless are
limitless you know it's it's ridiculous
and like you said yeah the government
right now by doing this is literally
saying that the states is pretty much
saying and stamping their approval on
something that doesn't exist guys I
should point out I know we've left this
out of the show credits Paul blah is
played by Carroll O'Connor I don't want
to let that go without pointing that out
next on we have to get off the
transgender thing that's all anybody
ever talks about these days
John McCain Senator John McCain
shockingly is attacking President Trump
here is to fear the world we have
organized and led the three-quarters of
a century to abandon the ideals we have
advanced around the globe to refuse the
obligations of international leadership
and our duty to remain the last best
hope of Earth for the sake of some
half-baked spurious nationalism cooked
up by people who would rather find
scapegoats and solve problems
eriell spurious means false does this
mean that john mccain only approves of
true nationalism well i think you know
he's served he's making a jab at the
america first agenda that donald trump
put forward and during this campaign i
think if we look at sort of you know i
do agree there were some things that
john mccain said that i did agree with
the idea that we are a nation united by
ideals I think what heard over the last
or last eight years was dividing a
nation by identity politics right and
actually this is something Alan Glu
eastcoast Razi and wrote about in the
closing American mine in the late 80s he
said you know mark my words we are a
nation that was founded on ideals but
increasingly and he observed this in the
60s increasingly there's a push to
divide us by you know what we don't have
in common which whether it be our race
our gender our sexuality and you know
I'm someone that I firmly believe that
we should be pushing back against that I
firmly believe that we should be
returning to this idea of uniting behind
ideals and I don't think America as the
abstract concept is divisive I think it
is representative of ideal so saying
America first isn't inherently divisive
in fact I think that's the attitude we
should be having and I think it's a
welcome departure from the last eight
years we've been cuckooing the idea of
American exceptionalism if we can
identify an objective good if we can't
say that America offers one of the best
systems in the world for women to
advance themselves you know if you go to
other countries across the globe there
are not the educational opportunities
career opportunities basic independence
that we have as women in America and I'm
comfortable saying we have a better
system I can't believe it I don't know
more shal can you stop this hateful
rhetoric can you please mute Ariel I
can't I'm gonna throw a desk or
something I know and so I don't have a
problem with the idea of saying you know
we have an awesome wonderful system and
we should celebrate that and that came
across in parts of the King's Speech but
I think just you know there have been
people nefarious elements especially
within the alt-right and we've seen it
with youth these scattered Nazi marches
I heard my god oohs I'm out right what I
don't know you've seen people warp that
message and use it to advance their
horrible agendas and I couldn't agree
more that's a problem but to say that
you know that's that fake patriotism is
what drives a majority the country I
don't look at 250
you know white supremacist buttheads in
Charlottesville
who don't deserve that time of day right
I don't I think that's a bad I wasn't
sure she said Butthead or something else
it's clarifying whether I get because I
do like you can't do it we have only the
highest standards here and I take your
point absolutely that's America I look
at you know what the people I run into
every day on the train who helped me
when I drop something or I look at you
know I look at America as being full of
people who I can connect with and if the
people I run into on the train are
America then this country is in a lot of
trouble mike is nationalism a bad word
nationalism isn't a bad word I mean
there's nothing wrong with saying that
our country is great and our country is
exceptional and our country is different
and unique in the history of mankind
because it is but I think John McCain
knows a thing or two about nonsense
patriotism he knows a thing or two about
chickenhawks he's been debating him his
whole career and he does a thing or two
about giving and sacrificing so much for
a war that might have been not well
conceived or or well thought of from
political standpoint what's fascinating
though about the John McCain versus
Donald Trump thing is my friends you
know in both parties who one day love
John McCain the next day hate him one
day think he's a hero the next day are
slamming him when he stands up that he's
going to vote for this they say oh he's
great and then I mean and this is really
indicative of politics in 2017 there is
no truth there is no sense of an
absolute war concept yeah thank yeah
that's that's an unfortunate product of
our post modernity but we're gonna try
to fix it here we're gonna keep
pandering like the New York Times says
we does pandering to our audience
because it likes the truth Mike thank
you for being here appreciate it I'll
see you next time a semi almost possibly
reasonable Democrat I'm Michael
Knowles's the Michael Knowles show come
back tomorrow and we'll do it all again
[Music]
you
[Music]